if you watched the Trump impeachment
inquiry hearings with us the last couple
of weeks you probably noticed this
Republican congressman Devin Nunez who
was doing a hell of a lot of talking
certainly more than I wanted to hear
from him the reason he was doing that is
he's the ranking member of the House
Intelligence Committee so he got to
issue opening and closing statements
right alongside the chairman of the
committee Adam Schiff and every time
Devin Nunez would go on and on about how
the ratings were down for the hearings
how the hearings were a waste of time
how there's simply nothing to see here
it's all pointless and Trump didn't do
any bribery corruption extortion quid
pro quo and he certainly wasn't looking
to force Ukraine to smear Biden or
looking for dirt on Biden and it now
turns out this has been a stunning
weekend of news that Devin Nunez himself
was allegedly involved in trying to find
smears of Joe Biden himself the calls
are coming from inside the house so to
speak Devin Nunez is part of the
impeachment hearings as a questioner of
witnesses he is now implicated in what
the impeachment hearings are meant to
investigate it's yet another person who
because of their personal conflicts and
in this case alleged corruption should
have nothing to do with the proceedings
whatsoever this is like Attorney General
Jeff Sessions recusing himself from
anything Russia related this is like
Attorney General William bar who right
now should be recusing himself from
anything Ukraine related that may come
before the Justice Department because of
his involvement and being implicated in
it devyn newness can't be investigating
this he's part of what we are trying to
investigate he should be a witness
answering questions not a member of the
committee asking them so I'll set this
up for you Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump's
lawyer I I struggle with what they even
call him now he is a lawyer who works
with or for Donald Trump or did at least
at one point Rudy has these two
associates who were recently arrested
left Parnas and Igor Froman the lawyer
representing one of them Lev Parnas said
that Parnas is ready to testify
oh that Devin Nunez himself met with a
former Ukrainian prosecutor Shokan in
2018 to talk about investigating Joe
Biden and his son hunter Biden Devin
Nunez reportedly went to Vienna Austria
to meet with Ukrainian prosecutor
general Viktor Shogun who is himself at
the center of a lot of what is going on
here shogun ended up being fired after a
whole bunch of leaders said this guy
isn't doing his job and of course Trump
says Shogun was fired in order to
protect hunter Biden now this might not
be true the allegation being made by
left Parnas here may be love Parnas is
making it up but number one it would be
extremely risky for left harness to be
making this up without being able to
have some evidence suggesting that it's
true and we will get to the topic of
evidence next because it turns out oh
lordy there are tapes but I don't want
to get ahead of myself
the allegations about Nunez do line up
with known facts about noonas having
meetings in Europe around this time
which by the way you the taxpayer paid
for and I'll get to that a little bit
later if this is true the hearings
themselves have been infiltrated by
people who should be targets of the
investigation
Devin Nunez shouldn't be asking
questions he should be answering them
the ranking member should be recognized
as a witness not as someone who gets to
participate in the hearings should any
of us be surprised about this Nunez is
the guy who while he was chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee back before
Democrats to control the house he was
supposed to be investigating Trump and
he was actually running to the White
House to let Trump know what they were
doing so it shouldn't be surprising this
is one of the dirtiest Republicans in
this entire Trump era and it's actually
even worse
not only did Devin Nunez apparently do
this he did it on taxpayer money he did
it with your money a new ethics
complaint claims that Devin noona spent
fifty seven thousand dollars in taxpayer
money to go to Europe himself and with
staff to try to dig up dirt on Joe Biden
and to convince European if
to get involved in the smears of Joe
Biden your money was spent on this they
need to get this guy off of the
committee and instead under oath himself
to answer questions he should recuse
himself immediately from any future
hearings even if only 5% of what's being
alleged is true and at this point even
talking about resignation is reasonable
here this is one of the dirtiest
dirtiest guys this is their hero from
the hearings along with Jim Jordan and
he is actually involved he's complicit
in what is being investigated but this
is not the only news from this weekend
related to Rudy Giuliani's associate
left arnis or what we learned from him
there is more and it is tapes let's talk
about that next I used to love cereal
when I was a kid and then I grew up and
I figured out it's filled with sugar
it's filled with carbs it's probably not
the best thing that I should be having
for breakfast this episode is sponsored
by magic spoon which is a new cereal
company that has discovered a way to
recreate our favorite childhood cereals
with zero sugar twelve grams of protein
and only three grams of net carbs per
serving they offer four flavors of magic
spoon breakfast cereal based on the
classics cocoa cinnamon frosted and
fruity plus a variety pack that lets you
try them all they've recreated the taste
and texture of classic sugary cereal it
tastes so incredible you would never
guess that it was virtually sugar-free
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb no GMOs my
favorite is definitely the cocoa I think
we all remember which cereal that one
reminds us of go to magic spoon comm
slash Pakman grab a variety pack and try
it today use our promo code Pakman at
checkout to get free shipping magic
spoon is so confident in their product
that it is backed with a 100% happiness
guarantee any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked go to magic
spoon comm slash Pakman and use the code
pa kma
for free shipping